i don't know how good looking this 12
year old is but everyone just falls in
love with him
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to episode one the pilot episode
optimistically of
she doesn't read the news with me chris
turner
and me your wife yeah she can't talk
without me saying she has permission
you may talk i give you permission for
the next half an hour to talk as much as
you want
darling thank you so much i'm so
appreciative for all the things you do
for me
um just this is a bit by the way i do
not wield the hand or something
cuff links into my belt that's in tenet
we watch tennis and it's very confusing
i didn't watch ten i walked out
but one of the highlights is kenneth
branagh putting his cufflinks
in his belt so when he's going to whip
elizabeth
drebecki she's going to be diana in the
next series of the crown
um it will hurt her more um we should
give you a behind-the-scenes
peek before we kick off we are recording
this in
my wife's family's gym we have a gym
room which is very exciting
and i went downstairs to get a lacroix
because
obviously and uh your dad was roaming
around the house heading this way
in his gym clothes
and i said i'm so sorry we're recording
and he said can't you do it
somewhere else and i was like uh we have
to do it now really because you know
otherwise
alice is gonna get tired and he went but
i just had my coffee
oh so he just had a coffee to get
himself all hyped up and caffeinated so
he could do half an hour in the
elliptical half an hour on the rowing
machine
and we've not let him come in here but
it's for a good cause
sort of a king lear situation playing
out there just noticed i've got
ink on my hands that's a macbeth
situation isn't it
out damn spot uh so just so you know
because this is the first time
in uh she doesn't read the news
basically my wife
does not read the news no that makes me
sound uh
very stupid um i just think it makes
people unhappy
i think that's true i think on balance
i'm a less happy person because i read
the news i think i mean
someone clearly has to read the news we
can't all not read the news
i think it's a bit like how we can't all
be buddhist monks but it's nice that
some people are out there being buddhist
monks i'm the buddhist monk
in this scenario the whole idea is i'm
gonna tell my wife
the biggest news stories of the week uh
and then at the end she gets to tell me
one thing that she's learned uh this
week not from reading the news but from
reading she's a reader so uh to kick us
off though i'm gonna give you guys and
her my
my news updates for the week i've had a
i've had a good week i've been doing
some shows
doing some virtual shows uh did
one for a university a kind of
involvement fair where i had to talk
about all of the activities that were
available and introduce various people
one of the awkward moments was when i
introduced the asian american
association and the man in charge of the
zoo called cut to
an asian american student who then
looked to the camera when
that's not my organization and then they
had to cut someone else who was then the
representative of the organization
and it was very tense and i could not
help myself from saying awkward
which i think is not what i should have
said it doesn't help it does not make
things less awkward
i did a bat mitts for this morning bat
mitzvah is uh
a bar mitzvah but for girls and for
those of you that don't know bar mitzvah
is a celebration for the the coming of
age of jewish children that's when
you're 12 or 13 as far as i'm aware
and uh i i was trepidatious about this i
thought this was going to be quite a
tough gig i had to get up really early
a audience of 30 13 year old girls isn't
my
ideal demographic i don't know if uh
anyone's heard me talk about my youtube
stats pretty much
95 men um and
it went remarkably well i had a lovely
time the
the girl celebrating was was wonderful
very very fun
um the best moment of it was someone in
the call
left their microphone on just as it was
about to start and we heard
the most stereotypical domestic row that
could ever be heard over zoom
where it was just a dad shouting at his
wife presumably
just going i told her she could watch it
here she's moved the laptop
she can watch it here see what i have to
deal with
and the phrase see what i have to deal
with is one of my fav i don't think i've
ever used that in a domestic dispute
no but i think you really should i feel
like you're missing out on a
on a trick there see what i have to deal
with um so that was that was my week it
was it was
you know chill it was good um i didn't
usually on those gigs for teenagers i'd
rather than come in and say hi i'm a
comedian i say hi i'm a youtuber
right because teenagers i mean i think a
youtuber
to a degree is a bit like being a pop
star which i mean chris is
not a monster sadly for both of us
but um yeah i think i think it is like a
viable career path they perceive in a
way that
is hard for us to imagine yeah they've
started asking if i'm a tick tocker
i have to i have to go a take water some
type of clock and they go ha ha he's so
old um do you talk uh yeah i talk
sometimes i tic i i didn't tell them
that i'm on youtube this time because
my latest youtube video is a pro
foreskin
right rap and so i didn't want to rock
up to a bat mitzvah and be like
sup guys check out my latest video all
about how foreskins are great don't chop
them off
um it includes the the line uh i know a
lot of jewish guys get the snip tell the
rabbi thanks guy you can keep the tip
that's quite good it's a great line but
i don't i'm not i'm not
overly keen on this video why
i find it a lit a little bit of vulgar
you find it objectifying
i think the stock footage you used of
the hot women was
uh yeah a little a little bit
objectifying
yeah she was very um scathing about the
fact that i
included hot women in my product to get
people to pay more attention to it
but then it's a bit hypocritical that
you've let me put you in this podcast oh
baby so sweet so sweet um if you haven't
heard it you can check it out on the
youtube channel i will put a little
a little clip of it now you can hear a
little sample of it now
foreskin i've got a foreskin just a
heads up baby it's a warning
i wanna make sure cause i've been burned
before when i show them my foreskin they
show me the door
girl i hope you've got an open mind
cause my dick's just like god designed
i've got a foreskin
girl let me be blunt there'll be a
little bit more going into your
however long that snippet was there rest
assured we sat here for the exact same
amount of time just in loving silence
so to get on with the news the news this
week there's it's
it's been a historic week it's a
momentous week it's a week
which made me think we should start this
what you'd know the biggest event of the
week right you know what
she's she doesn't really lose but she's
not i will tell you what happened
earlier this week which is that um i i
follow this guy on instagram
who makes 18th century garments and
as i was looking through his um feed he
had something like
everyone like deep breath for tomorrow
historic day
and i was like i wonder what that is so
i was like chris
what is this 18th century garment maker
saying about tomorrow
and chris just looked at me and he just
went the inauguration
alice and i was like oh this is how
oblivious you are a person who literally
lives in the 18th century
knew more about modern modern politics
than you no no okay all right
that was a low point um but so the
inauguration happened
biden is now president not my president
that's what a lot of people say well are
they still doing that they're still
doing that yeah
they think that um the plan is you don't
need to be
a member of the the house to be speaker
of the house
and so in two years they predict
there'll be a red
wave where republicans will win back the
house can then elect a speaker and
they'll pick
donald trump to be the speaker which
would then put him third in succession
they'd then impeach biden and harris
which means that donald trump would then
become automatic president
that's very elaborate it's very clever
which is why they're like don't worry
we're not going to impeach by
now we'll have to do it in two years
when trump's speaker of the house
as far as i can tell impeaching
presidents doesn't seem to have much of
an impact on whether they continue to be
presidents
not really not so far there was a poet a
young a very
amanda gordon young poet laureate did a
poem
and lady gaga did a song yeah that's and
joe biden not drew baiden
sorry bernie sanders were like a
hilarious um
i have something on later outfit and
everyone made memes so
alice is very aware of the memes that
went around right bernie had some
mittens that were knitted for him
for his campaign trail by a teacher i
think it was they were recycled
uh several of my raps this week have
been inspired by bernie's mittens people
who asked me to rap about those it was
very memorable i think meme of the week
and that's not going to be recurring
segment we're not doing meme of the week
i'm not one of those kind of people
um but yeah the integration it was a
paired down affair
so question because um i remember when
trump got inaugurated
there was like all this stuff about um
you know did anyone show up some people
said yes some people said no
uh presumably you can't have a big
group of people right now yeah so when
trump was inaugurated he was like it was
the biggest attendance ever and then the
national parks released photos being
like
it was not and he was like oh it's
because they put white coverings down it
show
people show up against it worse which
would make sense because his fan base is
entirely white
and it's actually not true not true of
course sorry
attempts at humor in this podcast will
be shot down by my wife
women aren't funny you see yeah the
inauguration was scaled back
however star power pretty impressive
right
he had i mean i i did get a list of the
people who
played at his inauguration right the foo
fighters katy perry
demi lovato bon jovi tom hanks hosted it
bruce springsteen
was on it loads of people lady gaga was
there obviously right
the funnest thing was to compare it to
trump's celebrity attendants
because he had do you remember who he
had um did he have three doors down he
had three doors down
a band that are they are they still
abandon
i don't i thought they must have like
reformed sure are they like
20 as good as panic at the disco is that
kind of
their situation i think they were they
were sort of like um
no i can't i can't really i don't know
any of their songs yeah i do actually
what are their songs kryptonite how does
that go
[Music]
okay yeah one of my joke i wrote but
never performed was superman
won't indulge in nocturnal necrophilia
he won't go to the crypt tonight
he's pretty good at it okay all right
but i want to say something about this
so
a while ago um sort of twice a month i
go on buzzfeed just to see if i'm old
yet
and you take a quiz that says are you
old
click these disney princesses we'll tell
you how old you are what kind of chair
are you um no so we should point out
that again if you're watching this
um alice is in quite a nice chair and i
am on a chair that frequently breaks
i've been doing live shows and i've had
to do extensive kind of
core squat strength to stay up because
this chair's gone crack and i've gone
oh mate you drop a mic at the end of a
rap you don't drop off a chair in the
middle of it
carry on sorry um so i i read this
buzzfeed article that it was like
famous celebrities you didn't know were
actually republican
and then it had this list of 30 people
no one has ever heard of i mean just
really they were scraping the barrel
just searching for
anyone you know mildly famous who they
could claim was republican
and the only thing is and i know i know
you're about to make fun of the
republicans for this and be like
lol isn't it funny that trump had no one
famous
and biden had all the famous people but
i can't help but feel that one of the
big problems between the left and the
right is that
the right feel that the left is smug and
a big part of that is
that hollywood et cetera are all left
wing no i think that's true um i think
aliens there definitely are republican
celebrities who hide it chris pratt
came out as republican and people like
jumped on him
um and the fun thing there was all his
marvel co-stars defended him
and it was like quite obvious that well
when all the kind of female members of
the mcu
and let me be straight couldn't give a
[ __ ] about the mcu
the marvel cinematic universe oh yes so
all those superhero movies that have
essentially ruined cinema by making
every big movie a superhero movie
that's that um everyone defended him but
they didn't defend you know all the
other
i don't even know their names because
again i don't watch the
the films some of the things from the
integration so they had high-end
security measures because
obviously like a couple of weeks before
we had the
so some people kidnapped some people the
capital was stormed
no i knew that i didn't know that i
thought but there was also a kidnapping
thing wasn't there
someone crashed gretchen whitmer had an
attempted kidnapping plot in about july
of last yeah that's all right that's
still pretty good
um the michigan governor i believe um so
they had
about 25 000 national guard troops and
they all stayed
in the capital and one of the scandals
i'm sorry
say that number again 25 000. so but um
there is a pandemic on now
so how are they how are those um are
they all just sort of diseased now yeah
i think i think so i think it was
so the the problem with that was they
made them sleep in the garage
how big is this carriage it's pretty big
have you seen american cars they're huge
i don't think it's big enough to fit 25
000 people there was there was a bit of
a
they weren't all in the capital but
there was a big scandal because they
were made to sleep in the
in the garage and aoc sent a tweet out
saying hey
anyone who wants to sleep in my office
um come we've got biscuits and you can
imagine showed up
oh my gosh i would have second i would
have put on camo and being there like
hello i'm a national guard can i sleep
in your office please aoc
um oh she's an absolute babe
one notable non-attendee was
uh was was trump there no trump didn't
go is that allowed
it's allowed it's the first time in like
150 years do you know who the last
person was who didn't show up so trump
is only the fourth person to skip it
out of 45 and the
last person to do it was andrew johnson
in 1869.
i think abraham lincoln is killed five
days after the end of the civil war
and then i believe andrew johnson takes
over from him
andrew johnson assumed the presidency as
he was vice president at the time of the
assassination of abraham lincoln
yes but the thing is he was vice
president but i believe he was of a
different party from abraham lincoln
so abraham lincoln was a republican yeah
he was a democrat who ran with lincoln
on the night and bear in mind obviously
so republican
back in the day meant like almost the
opposite of what a republican means now
um and so yeah so that's you know he
kind of
was going against a lot of what abraham
lincoln had set up
you know so he he went and like directly
undermined quite a few of
lincoln's early reconstruction things so
yeah a similar a similar vibe
of a president following someone who was
um politically and ideologically opposed
to him so he he didn't show up to
ulysses s
grant's inaugurations there yeah so
ulysses s grant was
was a republican i believe we mentioned
andrew johnson and i
uh will have edited this bit out but i
got a little bit confused with andrew
jackson
and andrew jackson was uh i think either
censured or impeached by
when he was president and well he was
quite a trump-like figure
so in the oval office you get to
decorate it when you move in right you
get to decorate the white house
trump famously um put gold rugs and
gold curtains in so i have a question
what is a gold rug is it stiff is it a
gold
sheet is it it's a gold colored rug all
right yeah like you have golden hair
it's not made of gold good explanation
thank you uh and he made the curtains
more gold than they used to be
and biden coming in has switched the
office back
and there was a big picture of andrew
jackson on the wall and he's taking it
down and put
franklin or someone on um and
one of the big scandals this week
scandal is a big word
is that trump had a bust of winston
churchill in the oval office
and biden's taking it out yes because
winston churchill has had a pretty
sharp turnaround in the last what 15
years i would say i would say up until
15 years ago
it was on problem it was considered
very normal to think of winston
churchill as a hero
and i really think in the last like it
feels recent
that has switched and people have
started focusing a whole lot more on on
his sort of is it genocide the famine he
yeah in india killed a lot of people i
think three million
that's a lobby it's quite so when you
really add it up it's more than
i've killed yeah
yeah we'll leave it at that we won't
give you a number but it's more than
that
um so he's taken out and apparently so
this happened when when obama was in
office he took the busted church
as well and trump put it back and
apparently boris johnson who's
churchill's his hero he's written he's
written biographies of churchill
he he's very angry he's angry just funny
because in picture and angry boris
johnson oh adorable he's so sweet he's
such a sweet little
angry man he's so
harmless you'd never think he's up to
any ever could he do anything he's
so bumbling our final thing we'll say
about trump there was a threat on his
life
is that true do you know that's a new
thing no but
this time is a bit more real um iran
the the leader of iran or if not the
leader you know there's i think iran has
like two leaders has the supreme leader
you don't sound as if you're speaking
with a great deal of confidence on the
screen
i think ayatollah khamani uh he tweeted
out
on twitter um a picture
of a fat man golfing shot from above
with a shadow of a bomber like over the
golf course
and then in farsi it said we will have
vengeance
[ __ ] twitter is so embarrassing you
guys like death threats used to be cool
do you know what i mean like it used to
come in these anonymous envelopes like
with anthrax now it's just [ __ ]
twitter how embarrassing i mean it's
pretty he
immediately got banned by the way the
guy's account because all the trump fans
were like what so
trump gets banned and you won't ban an
actual death threat
um he did get that doesn't seem fair you
should probably ban i mean the whole
twitter my god um okay so
so this dude in iran wants to kill trump
i mean i maintain
that doesn't seem like do you know why
they want to kill trump wasn't there a
big world war three almost thing
about a year ago yeah yeah so um let me
try and recap what i know of this
so um it was before covert it was like
the biggest no i know
so the reason i know about it is in all
the covered recap videos
everyone's like remember lol when we
thought it would be world war three and
then it wasn't
um and so no i don't remember anything
so his name was kassam solomani and he
was a top military general
egypt this week there was a big news
story from egypt something did happen
in egypt some people are going to go to
jail because they had a birthday party
and their cakes were a little salacious
they had a baker
make some cakes with buttocks and
boobies and willys on
which for americans are asses titties
and uh [ __ ] um and
there were photos on social media of
people like eating these cakes like
it's got a willy on it and they've
cracked down because in
in islam it is against against the
religion to
have cakes with genitals on and when
specifically this is a quote from the
economist when questioned
they could not point to where in the
quran it said that no but i think the
quran does say that you're not supposed
to
create images of exist like nature
like that's why so like in in mosques
and things it doesn't have like you know
paintings of muhammad it has
instead it has like shapes and geometric
patterns people are going to go to jail
because they had some willie cakes that
seem a bit extreme doesn't it
does seem a bit extreme but this is the
country that you know they had a me too
movement because people
accused certain big figures of molesting
them and harassing them sorry
men were molesting people i know it's
shocking only in egypt though we managed
to contain it and um
they arrested the men who did it but
then they also arrested the accusers and
the witnesses
there was a big thing in russia alice
now you you definitely know this
what happened in russia well in 1917
there was a very important
so in russia do you remember the the man
got poisoned they poisoned his tea
which is the most underhanded okay look
i actually don't feel to blame for this
it's very
hard to keep track of all the people
that russia poisons
which one are you talking about we have
met some people that russia
personally met people who russia is well
one person that's not that's not
nic we um wait what
let's not exaggerate okay cool she
speaks fluent french and it
pisses me off it's yes anyway but go on
say it's a it's a bone of contention as
you would say in france
um so they they poisoned uh navalny who
is a critic of putin and the leader of
the opposition party
and wait i do know something about
russia didn't an american man fly over
to russia
i mean i'm sure it's happened at some
point wasn't there like isn't there some
kind of guy
my mother was talking about this and she
said he's a republican and a hero
uh which is surprising for her because
she's you know she's very very
anti-republican
but um he the russians hate him and he
flew
to russia anyway so this i think you're
talking about the same person
so this is navalny who is hate putin and
putin
hates him he made a big video called
like the the biggest bribe or something
which is all about how putin
takes a lot of money and gives it to all
his cronies putin really does look like
a bond villain doesn't he oh yeah i mean
it's not have you ever seen the page
where he's in a submarine that's on its
way down and he's just looking out for
the little submarine hatch
and it just looks as if he's just this
bond villain like leaving at the end of
the film
to return and the next one like he's so
he is evil
looking but like quite hot very scary
man i put him
so one year i made my brother a um a
calendar of hot villains from history
and i had quite a sexy picture of putin
in it
who are some of the others do tell well
i think the obvious one is we've all
we've we've all wanked over stalin right
young stalin is
young star old star i don't even mind
that mustache
his hair he must hit maybe it's just a
good picture that's
you know some people say that uh young
stalin was [ __ ] hot
the thing with stalin you know he was
very good at getting rid of pictures
because he used to erase people out of
pictures when he killed them so they
don't they don't exist anymore
yeah i don't know that that was that was
the i mean he was the real winner i gave
him december because that's
you know yeah who are some other hot
villains because i think people are
listening to you being like you better
not put hitler in you didn't play i
didn't put hitler in i'm sorry hitler
not not because of his politics he just
wasn't a fitting well he wasn't yeah
he was no oil painting but he did love
oil painting
he didn't really actually prefer
watercolors ceausescu
yes yeah cha cha chancheski was the
yeah i think the in bucharest he was the
romanian dictator yeah
yeah right right right some baddies who
were baddies
because baddie is slang term for
attractive yeah yeah since
she's a baddie never heard that well it
is are you sure yeah
where did you find it on tick tock urban
dictionary that i'm gonna add now before
you get a chance to
check it he's returned they immediately
arrested him
they he recovered in germany for five
months from being poisoned he
immediately returned they immediately
arrested him and they've been the
biggest protest against putin in russia
uh since putin came to power since then
and
the russians have just treated it by
putting everyone in jail
in the uk uh where we used to live
there they've had been a bit of worry
recently because obviously
they're in quite a big lockdown at the
moment and they're planning on doing
that until mid february because and it
snowed
and it did snow that's that's the news
that alice knows is from our what's up
group where someone sent a photo out of
their window and said
it snowed i think i'm up to date on most
of the important you're up to date on
them yeah yeah
oh it's cool so the most important thing
there is there's a lockdown because
there's a variant in the uk off kovitz
yes it's much much more contagious much
more contagious one of the policies that
leaked this week
and ministers in the uk some of them
agree some of them don't
and let me see what your thoughts are
and if you can spot the flaw in this
strategy
we're proposing to give everyone who
caught covid
a single one-off payment of 500 pounds
now this is on top of the money that the
government has been giving people anyway
obviously i think three million people
who are self-employed have still been
left out
are they trying to pay people to get
coveted they are paying people to get
covered that's the big flaw in the plan
well i don't understand so what what is
the um
argument they're saying if you've got
covid we need you to stay home for two
weeks
and stop going out and spreading it and
a lot of people who have coveted are
still going out because they need to
earn money to live
right yeah they're saying we'll give you
this money along with universal credit
and the other welfare schemes that they
have which are not enough
stay home but the floor and the plan is
people then were like
brilliant well who's go it's like those
um chicken pox parties
right where kids oh you've got
chickenpox everyone come around and have
a bloody rave and then you rub your kid
against another kid and
that sounds horrible i guess you could
make the argument
um sorry i got distracted by a rogue cat
so we have the cat here we're now on to
a segment that i'm inventing and i'm
going to call
australia news going on dan and dap
um we we love australia we've been to
australia a couple times the australian
government
has said to google that they need to
start paying
the people whose news they aggregate so
google like you know we'll put a news
story
we'll like you know on your search
results we'll give you a news story from
a website
and you might read the news story
directly on google
goodbye cat the australian government
have said oh mike you've got to
you've got to pay for that you've got to
pay royalties the only reason for this
section is that you like doing your
australian acceptance
yeah you're not doing an australian
accent enough i can't you know i can't
the australian government has said to
google you need to start paying
royalties
otherwise we're gonna you can't be in
australia
and google said all right yeah google
said all right well you can do an
american accent for google they're
american what's google
said uh no i don't i don't know what
i've google said
what do you think a massive tech
corporation have said oh yeah we'll pay
you money
they said they're gonna pull out of us
yeah they said you don't get any google
then
god so they're all going to be using
yahoo i mean i guess so
australia for years didn't have netflix
or amazon
and to be honest they were probably fine
we'll see what happens maybe next time
we go to australia
we'll be like i don't know let me google
it and the police are gonna be like oh
excuse me mate now you have to bloody
big it
you've got to bring it australia uses
verbs in a very funny way and i can
imagine that oh bloody being
god he's a proper being so uh bing
bing crosby that's where it comes from i
don't think so where does bing come from
it's just a nice sound is it nice is
that what it is yeah
google yahoo google ding yahoo
ask dreams the alice is so british that
that's the only one she uses
oh james would you please i don't want
to ask anyone but my valid when i have a
question about how to get to
nando's nando's you've never beaten us
you've never even i have eaten another
okay name three sizes uh they have fries
curly fries and cheese fries
probably balls rubbish macho peas mate i
have been and it was actually quite
lovely i have to say
yeah what um what what chicken did you
get i don't eat chicken as well you know
you don't eat chicken
oh don't eat chicken um so we've we've
had we've had the australian segment it
was
a roaring success that's going to be
coming back for next episode
um this this segment this little thing a
little bit i'm inventing it's called
breaking news it's a news story from
today
so it's even less likely that you'll
have heard it um my breaking news story
today
do you know who jojo c was different
from jojo who sang
get out right now
you know she was 14 when she sang that
really she was go on
is that the jojo it's only a year away
from the people who wrote my bat mitzvah
um i could have had jojo there no jojo c
well you don't know who jojo siwa is
look i i tiny cute blonde girl wears
massive hair bows
oh the massive hair bow girl yeah okay
wait so let me tell you what i know
about her um
recently people made fun of her for her
massive hair bows so then she started
wearing not massive hair bows and was
like actually there's more to me than my
hair voice
okay so the news article that i learned
this from led with
jojo siwa famous for her massive hair
bows so she's not really managed to
rebrand herself that much away
um the breaking news about her is and
she's beloved she's got like 10 million
instagram followers
she's like she's from a show called
dance moms as far as i'm aware
and i think that's quite a popular show
watched by everyone
um and the big news is that she has just
come out she did it by
posting a picture on instagram or
twitter of her
saying my cousin just bought me a shirt
and the shirt says best
gay cousin ever and i think people were
confused they were like
is that your cousin and they're really
arrogant they're like
yeah wear this um i mean look i have
merchandise available such as the 9th
century crop rotation hat and t-shirts
they dropped the beat good sir
and it was just my nephew's birthday and
i did send him a chris turner t-shirt to
wear
um that's a lie i sent him a kiss
t-shirt because he loves kids obsessed
with kids
absolutely legend uh okay so she she
came out
um as uh as she hasn't come out
yeah it's sort of unclear now i feel
like i feel like if you came out 10
years ago everyone was like well you're
a lesbian but if you came out now people
are like
you could be non-binary you could be
yeah we could just be sort of
there's like so many different yeah
she's come out and she she just she just
said hey
guys are great women are great people
are great and then obviously the replies
to her tweet suggest that people are not
great people are massive pieces of [ __ ]
but i do think that that's the kind of
like because i think she has a very wide
appeal
i do i think she has appeal with people
who would usually not
not know gay people yeah exactly so i
think that's actually really um
i mean quite brave of her because i i
could imagine that that could have a
negative impact on her numbers
or you know what it will have it'll it
it may shift her audience
right because she might lose some
numbers and gain others right
other people will be more interested in
her but uh still i mean that must be
she's like a teenager how old i think
she's 17 yeah i mean
it's so difficult being 17 to begin with
add to that having to come out to 10
million people what a [ __ ] night yeah
i mean one of the things i'm worried
about with this podcast is by coming out
as having a wife
i'm going to lose a lot of all the
ladies who love watching me and they're
like oh he's not single this is
disgraceful
chris really you know to preserve your
mystique you ought to be sexually
available at all times
we've had the week's news and that's all
the news that you don't need to know
anything else that's all the news that
happened
it's time for your news because you
don't read the news but you do read
so what i've said is you get to tell us
something that you've learned not from
the news
but from reading this week so
the floor is yours educate us i i have
been reading a lot of uh
medieval um english romances
so uh i'm gonna tell you a little bit
about king horn
which is horn now before you get too
excited he is a child yeah so king horn
king horn is one of the earliest uh
middle english romances he's often put
in the same category as other romances
like somebody
clarify romances which means stories um
well yeah well sort of
that's a complicated question romances
um you know it comes
it came from france um eleanor of
aquitaine brought
um basically troubadours and the idea of
chivalry over from france
just assume that everyone knows what
aquitaine troubadours and chivalry
are um uh but yeah so
a medieval romance it's not like you
know it's a love story there is
usually elements of a love story in it
uh but
it's a story about knights basically
it's about this prince
called uh prince horn who um he his
his island is invaded by um just wicked
evil saracens they're just so evil these
are the saracens
are well it's sort of unclear in
medieval literature theoretically
they're muslims right it's the crusades
but um the way that the saracens are
described shows a really only passing
understanding of what islam is
and it's just other right it's just
different from us all we know is they
did not have cakes with genitals on
definitely none of those but so um the
saracens these evil wicked saracens come
and they uh burn down all the churches
because they're pagans
and they kill all the children in the
land and they kill the king
but when they get to horn he's like 12.
and he's so fit he's so attractive
that they're like wow we know that
you're going to grow up and be really
angry at us for destroying your island
and killing your father but we just
can't kill you're just too handsome
so instead they let him and a coup like
couple of his friends go on a boat
and he gets on a boat and he washes up
on a different shore
and um this king of this new island
sees him and is like holy [ __ ] you are
so han
like wow he like i don't know how good
looking this 12 year old is but everyone
just falls in love with him um so he
gets adopted
and um then various things happen
he falls in love with um riemann hill
the princess of the court
but he's betrayed by his cruel friend
fickenhald
uh anyway so he ends up killing tons and
tons of saracens to prove his love for
rivenhilld
how many i think he kills at least a
hundred in one afternoon because in
these romances
essentially the knights are superheroes
this was the mcu
of the past that's actually a quite a
good analogy yeah absolutely thank you
that'll be your dissertation if you are
doing an english degree
write a dissertation on why medieval
romances were the mcu of their time well
it's also very related to sort of fan
fiction
or i mean it just it all plays into each
other right
you might read a romance about gawain
and be like oh i like that bit of gawain
so i'm going to take gawain and add him
into my story about you know
also it's like dc versus marvel that he
kills
hundreds of saracens in one afternoon
even though he's uh apparently
13. um he's very small they can't like
get him
they're like slicing over his head and
he's down there at one point he's like
messy
he comes back to his island and the
saracens there are like oh
we should have killed you but you are
just so
hot um and so then he kills all of them
and then he becomes
uh king of his island which is called
sudanese
um which so he's actually pseudonym i
don't yeah i don't think so what a twist
at the end
boom i don't think he is sudanese but
yeah it's a weird island
um and he marries roman hild and lives
happily ever after
oh that's not well thank you for
teaching about king horn obviously i am
renowned for my freestyle raps and
people often ask me they're like oh
doesn't isn't your wife lucky that she
gets freestyle raps all the time
isn't she we're going to finish off with
a freestyle based on any of the topics
that we spoke about today we're
definitely including king horn what else
would you like me to wrap up so king
horn
um andrew johnson not going to ulysses s
grant's inauguration
boris johnson being angry about the
winston churchill bust
being removed uh jojo siwa is
more than just hair bow girl yeah
and russians choosing to poison people
using adorable cozy methods like cups of
tea
great here we go
wide mouth slap jaw like a yawn when i
see a fit child and i call him king horn
now i better make clear everybody agrees
he's the most handsome kid that can ever
exist
only 13 king amongst all the men
see their little horn slaying all the
saracen get the scimitar
cutting off their knees then he goes
gets his wife she'd be like jeez
you're so attractive and you caught all
the people revenge on them
now they're equal coming for a sequel
gonna do
killing if you sit there with the
beverage chilling
watch out for the russian creeping up
behind you alexi novony we
find you and so we take a little bit
polonium put it in your milk
you go down now killed by the kgb
now the fsb now putin coming over
in your mouth with the poison you should
always be aware i can kill
everybody like a riding a bear but alexi
survive
no perishing five months later he
arriving
on a plane in russia he like let's go
back home and stand against putin in
moscow
clapton iron they threw him all away bye
bye russian accent no more with you our
play
take it out of there like a churchill
bust clean it up
nicely none of that rust trump put it
back once obama removed then biden came
out he's a very old dude he was like oh
i'm not into you mr winston you killed
them in
india how many three million three
million
it's not on time not b i'm killing them
that's okay though
get it out put it in storage boris
johnson
couldn't ignore it he's like wow this is
totally outrageous
come on tropido should do me a favor put
it right back
what do you say fighters like i don't
care about the uk yeah you guys are on
your own
try and understand you did the brexit
just a lonely island and that's not a
reference to comedy rap groups
talking about this jojo siwa with the
big hoops and a big bow but it's not
just these
she came out online people start jia
ring at her and saying oh i don't lie
anymore and she's like i don't even care
i don't adore all the haters
see you guys later the beats gone over
that please do me a favor remind me what
the latin was that we need to do oh yeah
ulysses i'm done with you we fit you in
right here at the end
andrew johnson not your friend because
he didn't come immigration did not
attend you were there standing outside
the kappa all looking for andrew peering
at the mall saying
yo johnson where you gone eh bro you
should have showed up mr
aj and he was like no i don't fancy that
you're republican and i'm democrat i was
the party of lincoln
i'm the vp but then he got shot in his
head t
he and obviously he's happy because that
raised him to power which is what kamala
harris thinks will happen
in a few hours um there's that's a good
punchline to finish off
i'm not saying kamala's going to kill
joe just saying that you know
when he dies she will be like oh that's
bad news
anyway let's uh let's put that busted
churchill back in i love him she's
actually part indian so she would not
well i wanted to say i'm actually i just
want to check i don't think i'm 100 sure
about that number three million so don't
quote me on
it how many okay let's have a look the
1943 famine in bengal
killed up to three million people that's
a [ __ ] ton of people all in bengal
i'm glad you didn't cheer then i thought
you were gonna be like yes no because
you got it right and then i would have
cut it out and be like where's the
church to kill three million people
yes listen to our podcast uh
yeah no that's that just in bengal [ __ ]
that's pretty bad yeah
i mean india's massive yeah but it's
huge like there's a lot of people in
bengal sure
i'm not saying that's i'm not saying
it's a good thing i'm just saying that's
you know that's a huge number anyway i
knew the number so i i guess that's good
i
clearly haven't have been taking in the
searing facts of the last century yeah
so i mean anyone who's interested in um
learning more about
you know all the obscure stuff that my
wife knows about you can follow where
can we follow you well my instagram is
where i review my books
uh at let them eat books with
underscores instead of spaces
you can so go ahead yeah find her on
there and i am obviously on chris turner
comedy on instagram and chris pj
turner on youtube do give this a
subscribe we'll be putting some out
weekly
um and if you go to the youtube if
you've been listening this you can watch
this as
a video there'll be a link to the video
podcast of this
as well alex thank you very much for
hanging out with me you are
beautiful it's a pleasure i love you
very much and thank you for that
handshake
um hopefully one day you'll let me kiss
you on the cheek
don't hold your breath see you guys next
week